[Music]
you have many fans which is a blessing
but some of them uh have too much time
on their hands and there's a website
called that someone has constructed
called emotions with john hamm my least
favorite three words are there's a
website yeah yeah mine too uh
this is called emotions with john hamm
and it it it shows all of the emotions
different photos of you both of them
yeah
in different emotions can you take us
through what these emotions are because
this is put a lot of work into this like
let's just scroll through these first
john now that is
that's uh that's that's unfettered
arousal unfettered arousal all right
what's next you see like okay
uh that is uh right before midday nap
nice okay it's coming up next and then
we got oh wow back to arousal
and
wow i like this guy ah
that one is i think just uh post climax
yeah post climax
next we got another one oh what are you
doing there uh i think that's i think i
just farted yeah okay
next one that explains jen's like oh god
what happened
uh oh oh my god that's my favorite
i like to call that one tuesday
very nice
very nice